vous savez cyril à la pitié salpêtrière
et dans les hôpitaux de france et dans
les services spécialisés on est
confronté à une misère qui est la misère
du coc vide à la fois la mort les gens
en réanimation mais cette maladie elle
aussi responsable d'une autre misère et
qui est aussi une misère sanitaires et
on a très peur que le jour où on va on
espère sortir de cette maladie il va y
avoir des sortes d'effets secondaires
pardon ne se termine tout petit peu
médicales liées à cette crise
je vois déjà dans le service où je suis
dans les consultations parce qu'il n'ya
pas que des consultations qu'ovide le
nombre de dépressions le nombre
d'anxiété majeur les insomnies et on a
très très peur même d'autres choses donc
il faut absolument penser alors
heureusement qu'on n'ait pas mis la
plaque
oui non concernant le confinant parce
que nous n'avions pas le choix on se
doit quand même de répéter parce que là
on est tous concernés par notre système
hospitalier en oublie le coc vide en
oublie le vide
il faut regarder notre système
hospitalier nautisme hospitalier
aujourd'hui en particulier en
réanimation
on est à 4800 lit on en avait ça mille
on a mis 5800 on sait qu'on pourra
monter un petit peu mais ça c'est
uniquement qu on vide les 30 % qui
restent ou les 20% de libre si demain
vous moi il a ça concerne tout le monde
pas simplement les personnes à risque ça
concerne le tout venant
on aura besoin de ces lits de
réanimation en hospitalisation n'est à
31500 occupation cd 32 milles au mois
d'avril uniquement qu'ovide la hausse il
n'y a pas que le coc vide dans ma
spécialité on allait sida des compensées
on a des infections des tuberculoses des
affections respiratoires majeur alors il
ya un moment si vous voulez pour pas que
le système explose et ans est la valeur
la valeur que représente la santé il
fallait faire quelque chose
alors est ce qu'on l'a bien fait est ce
qu'on n'a pas bien fait on l'a fait trop
tard pas trop tard on pourra y revenir
mais il ya un moment où vous êtes
complètement acculé ça a été ça a été la
même chose au moins 2 au mois de mars
quand on a pris cette décision il ya un
moment où vous n'avez pas le choix sinon
tout explose et la santé si vous voulez
enfin personne ne pourrait pardonner à
un gouvernement de laisser ou un parent
dont 40 de 1500 morts entre eux octobre
septembre octobre car presque douze
mille morts supplémentaires
on est plus à 30 milles en a 10 ans 10
trente mille quarante deux mille cinq
cents ans et j'aime pas cette
comptabilité morbide mais elle est quand
même une personne aujourd'hui qui
meurent sur quatre c'est le premier
ministre a rappelé ses locaux vides
ça c'est une réalité et à côté de ça
madame moi je je suis très ému parce
qu'on est spécialiste mais on est
médecin on est aussi des hommes et je
vois autour de moi je vois aussi moi
j'ai envie de chialer
aussi quand je vois ça quand je compte
quand je vois les commerçants alors on
pouvait peut-être faire différemment je
me permettrai pas madame la ministre de
donner des conseils mais quand je vois
par exemple sur les commerces en
particulier c'est qu'il ya une étude aux
états unis qui a montré que les lieux de
contamination mais alors en premier ça
c'est l'étude c'est les bars les
restaurants on peut comprendre on peut
comprendre le lien social on boit un
petit byrne enlève le masque on mange il
ya une contamination
les petits commerces arrive très très
bas en allemagne on a dit voilà votre
boutique votre local il fait 25 mètres
25 mètres carrés en ferme tout ce qui
est supérieur à 25 mètres carrés en
laisse ouvert en fait les distanciation
social entre même faire à l'extérieur et
on sait que la ventilation à l'extérieur
même si c'est un petit peu froid mais
enfin il vaut mieux avoir froid que
attraper la co vide
donc voila c'était peut-être des choses
qu'il fallait faire et là si vous laisse
de voir tous ces magasins fermés et puis
parfois aussi pardon mais la justice
parce que parce que le médecin que je
suis fais aussi des cours je suis allé
dans un dans un supermarché le masque
sous le nez une foule pas possible mal
ventilée donc on ne peut pas ne pas se
poser de questions et donc on a envie de
dire sortant vite sortant vite
évitons si vous voulez la pathologie
sociale et la pathologie mentale pardon
d'utiliser ce mot qui risquent
d'apparaître